[Music]
you ball is a classic example for me
from an evolutionary standpoint of germs
and parasites being your real enemy as a
big animal on a multicellular organism
everybody's terrified of Ebola because
you can't see it and the way as they say
as the saying goes this is not my idea
people aren't afraid of dying so much as
they're afraid of how they're gonna die
and the Ebola death looks horrible man
it's awful and what's making it worse in
Africa in particulars scientific
illiteracy people not realizing that
these microorganisms get passed from one
to another when I was in South Africa uh
I guess five years ago a guy told the
story he was from a village a small
village is working for the South African
space agency which they have and he says
it's going to villages where kids have
never seen a magnet and you they
recommend that you don't go near that
tree because the lightning bird landed
on that tree and that means that tree
will get struck by lightning and the
tree branch will fall on you and that's
not true by the way so by having a
population of people who don't really
understand germs and how serious they
are the germ gets spread really readily
as far as people freaking out here in
the US it's appropriate however the same
legislators who when it comes to climate
change say well I'm not a scientist I
can't have an opinion on climate change
sure have a lot of opinions about Ebola
there is a faction of our leaders
elected officials who continually cuts
the budget for the Centers for Disease
Control which to me reflects an
ignorance of how serious germs can be I
remind us all that in 1918 more people
died of what was called the Spanish flu
then died from World War one which
killed a lot of people
the Spanish flu killed estimates vary
but about 50 million 50 million people
died of the flu and when you think of
the flu you think I well you flu you
take theraflu you take chicken soup
you'll be fine what cannot take
penicillin ineffective against the virus
people not going to help you penicillin
is not going to do anything against it
boy with that said it's very reasonable
that researchers diligent researchers
will be able to develop a vaccine
against Ebola it's very reasonable and
so in my opinion we should be supporting
that research full-bore but at the same
time don't curtail research in other
germs which is going on at the Centers
for Disease Control for example all the
time this is not it that's not where you
save your money Congress but if you
don't believe in the seriousness of it
and you have a mistrust of scientists if
you have a mistrust of engineers you're
you're not gonna help us out with that
are you so it's very serious concern of
mine
and if everybody we're talking about
climate change that we were talking
about Ebola we'd be working on climate
change pretty steadily also so I'm it's
another lesson
you know we on on my side of it in the
science education world I mean this
whole thing is so frustrating the United
States used to be the world leader in
technology but when you have this group
of leaders elected officials who is who
are anti science you're setting the us
back and then ultimately setting the
world back so we should support the
health workers that are willing to take
the risks and go to the hot zone we
should support African governments and
enable to the extent possible science
education so that people have more more
literate about this it's a really
difficult problem but solvable solvable
problem I'd like to make another comment
that occurred to me
as an engineer everybody I saw a story
this morning about these home elevators
that have ruined people's lives they've
kids have gotten there these horrible
head injuries from home elevators which
aren't subject to the same standards as
elevators and commercial buildings and
it's another thing where if you had
extraordinary supervision over children
they wouldn't get in this trouble on the
other hand if the elevators were
designed better the kids wouldn't get in
this trouble and it just shows you how
much we need how much we rely on
Engineers I'm sorry these people who
designed the elevators did their best
they didn't think of the ten-year-old
getting his head trapped in there but
after it happens we can make design
changes so it never happens again when
people apparently loaded up their key
chains so they're so heavy that they
were able to overcome the detent the
stop the can't turn it past part of the
ignition switch these chevrolet vehicles
then people crash the cars because
somebody in the ordering department
thought it was okay to have the the pin
a little shorter than it was last year
and so the pin didn't hold the detent as
it's called the stop as strongly and it
was able to cause these enormous
problems we rely on engineers to solve
these problems and I as an engineer we
do our best we anticipate these things
but you can't anticipate everything and
this is part of evolution future
ignition switches will not have that
problem for a number of reasons first of
all some people got seriously injured
and then we have laws to hold
corporations accountable for these
serious injuries and then we have
systems in the corporation to make
changes and enforce it this is
civilization and it's top-down and
bottom-up at once and I as an engineer
just want to remind people just how how
many moving
arts there are in a car and how well
they work I'm not making excuses just
saying stop and appreciate how
complicated these things are and now we
all take it for granted and they are all
absolutely a result of science literacy
if having a population of people who
understands the significance of science
in our every state everyday lives and to
ask you that or set it aside or not
support basic research is not in
anybody's best interest this is not a
controversial statement but somehow I
find it very frustrating when stuff like
that happens and we all take it for
granted
so I'll start pointing fingers without
realizing what's involved we can change
the world people we can change the world
let's go
you